[Music]
a military ceremony as the newly
inaugurated french president reviews the
troops
but there was no drive down the
champs-elysees on saturday
just a few hundred people including
macron's only surviving predecessors
francois hollande and nikola sarkozy
were there for the swearing-in
first of all we'll act to avoid
escalation after russia's aggression in
ukraine will act to help democracy and
triumph to build a new european peace
and a new autonomy on our continent
macron's the first french leader in 20
years to serve a second term he's
expected to name a new prime minister
before leading his rebranded centrist
party now called renaissance into june's
parliamentary elections
[Applause]
we'll act to make our country the great
ecological power it should be by
radically changing our means of
production and transport and our way of
life we'll continue to tackle
inequalities at the root by rebuilding
our schools and health systems
but many voters are skeptical about his
ability to tackle burning issues such as
rising prices
i'm expecting a much bigger social
crisis than during his first term
it felt like the first mandate was aimed
at the richest in society
so i hope we see the trickle-down
promise during the first term take place
during the second
the french already have a cost of living
problem some can't afford to feed
themselves so i fear there could be a
new yellow vest crisis
that's a reference to widespread street
protests by the chilejon or yellow vests
movement which led to macron promising
tax cuts and pension rises
macron also faces a real challenge when
it comes to controlling the national
assembly
jean-luc melenchon heads the left-wing
party la france and sumis france unbowed
he almost reached the second round of
the presidential vote at the expense of
the far right now he's hoping to be the
next prime minister supported by a
coalition including the weakened
socialist party as well as the greens
and the communists
whether macron can stop him may depend
on how far he can convince the
electorate that he understands the scale
of the economic crisis
nadim baba al jazeera